welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and barberheimer weekend has
arrived Christopher Nolan Oppenheimer
versus credit gerwig's Barbie they're
both releasing in theaters right now and
all summer long entertainment media has
been hyping up this weekend as some kind
of Clash of the Titans you got your
Atomic Big Boy versus the plastic big
doll but if you can only see one this
weekend or if you're trying to figure
out what order to watch them in or just
how to mentally approach these movies I
got you covered with a double review and
an analysis of The Uncanny historical
parallels between these releases they're
kind of perfectly matched if you ask me
a match made in Hell quick note here
sag-aftra has informed us that
entertainment journalism Outlets like
new rockstars are allowed to do reviews
and Analysis of movies and TV shows
without violating any strike rules they
actually want us to review these movies
they want these movies to perform well
so that the actors and writers get the
successes they deserve what you're going
to see here is a critical review and an
analysis not a paid promotion we support
the actors and writers on strike and we
join their call to the am PTP to come
come back to the table and negotiate in
good faith first why the hell are Barbie
and Oppenheimer released in the same
weekend anyway why do we have to fight
why make us choose well Christopher
Nolan has almost always released his
films in the third weekend of July The
Dark Knight The Dark Knight Rises
Inception Dunkirk the original release
date of tenet before kovid pushed it
back that third weekend of July is a
sweet spot and so last year Nolan
released the first Oppenheimer teaser
claiming this release date The Numbers
dropping like thuds on Robert Downey
Jr's words but until 2021 Christopher
Nolan has almost always released his
movies through Warner Brothers in 2021
due to covid Warner decided to release
most of their theatrical films with the
exception of tenet on HBO Max Godzilla
vs Kong Mortal Kombat Dune the Matrix
resurrections Wonder Woman 84 all came
out on HBO Max this made Christopher
Nolan piss along with many directors
because most film directors make movies
to be shown on big screens and they
believe that exclusive streaming
releases cheapens the art form and they
are not wrong so for Oppenheimer Nolan
left Warner Brothers and he took this
film to Universal and they rolled out
the red carpet for this Prestige
filmmaker and they poured a ton into the
marketing for the film which is why
alongside Barbie somehow Oppenheimer has
still been hanging in there meanwhile
Warner Brothers looking for a summer hit
to counter program against Oppenheimer
selected Reddit gerwig's Barbie a comedy
and satire with fun party Vibes and
aimed more at women but really it's a
movie for everybody why pick the same
weekend and go head to head well there's
actually historical precedence
specifically with Christopher Nolan in
2008 Nolan's The Dark Knight came out
this same July weekend with Warner
Brothers while Universal counter
programmed with the release of Mamma Mia
the musical adaptation with Meryl Streep
Now The Dark Knight of course went on to
become one of the most profitable films
of all time but don't sleep with Mamma
Mia Mamma Mia also broke records in its
respective categories it was really a
win-win for both Studios and the motion
picture industry as a whole it was
actually a good thing that Universal
picked that weekend to release Mamma Mia
to counter program because people were
just going to the movie theaters and
sometimes people just wanted another
option of a movie to see because at the
end of the day folks us content creators
are not in competition with each other
we're in competition of other ways
people can spend their time like playing
video games or reading or going out side
boo so how does all this set the stage
for barberheimer well Barbie is almost
certain to win the weekend by a wide
margin why well the movie is shorter one
hour 54 minutes compared to
oppenheimer's three hours and therefore
Barbie can play on 1.5 more screens this
weekend and give viewers way more
options to see it Oppenheimer will
definitely be supported by the Nolan
diehards of which there are many while
the movie seems like homework I think
it's the kind of homework that might
carry with strong word of mouth in the
second third fourth and fifth weekends
and before I review each film here is my
recommendation of which order to see
them in and feel free to disagree with
me but I think you should see Barbie
first and then watch Oppenheimer now if
you already bought your tickets and
you're doing it the other way around
that's totally fine the other way works
too like if you're already someone who's
committing to see both of these movies
opening weekend that means you're just a
hungry film goer and you're gonna have a
blast whatever order you see them in but
I'm talking to everybody else out there
the uncertain crowds the people on the
fence the people who aren't really sure
if they're gonna spend their week and go
into a movie yet to all of you I say
Barbie first and then Opie why that
order well Oppenheimer in my opinion is
the better film it's a more profound
film going experience an Oppenheimer is
more likely to stay with you and fill
your weekend with interesting
conversations between you and your
friends and your family Barbie
comparatively is like a scatter shot
experience that casts a wide subject
matter net on a lot of issues that may
result in some debates and division
among your community so quick review of
Barbie Brandon awake accomplishes
something remarkable she tells the story
of Barbie as an iconic American product
since 1959 both the good and the bad of
that and Barbie's relationship to our
culture as a film nerd I loved how
Gerwig rooted her story in the themes of
The Wizard of Oz in 2001 A Space Odyssey
giving me a new appreciation
understanding of two films I thought I
already overthought to death Margot
Robbie and Ryan Gosling give the best
performances of their career I'm not
kidding and don't tell our Marvel
followers but simulu and Kingsley
benedir are way more entertaining than
this than they are in the MCU now my
gripes with the movie are really just
that at times it does feel overwritten
Greta Gerwig seems to be trying to solve
every societal ill I think there's not
enough visual storytelling really every
visual is just kind of called out and
described at length through dialogue but
hey I think that's an admirable flaw for
this film I'd rather something be
overwritten than underwritten though
some of the world logic does fall apart
in the second act gets a little lost at
times as to whose story this is but it
all comes together in the end with some
of the most iconic and quotable lines of
dialogue I have heard in a film in this
decade I think I prefer Greta gerwig's
work in Little Women and ladybird but
Barbie is just a goofy hilarious sexy
Beach Musical with great songs and a lot
of nerdy film references I had a blast 8
out of 10. July is primo Blockbuster
season so if you want to spend more of
your free time at the theater spend less
time in the kitchen by letting Factor do
the work for you factors fresh never
frozen meals are ready in two minutes
which leaves you plenty of time to get
to the theater early enough to watch the
trailers what can I say I obviously love
trailers factor is America's number one
ready to eat meal kit you've heard me
talk about hellofresh but factor is now
owned by hellofresh I use both my life
is twice as easy twice as tasty Factor
lets me skip shopping shopping prepping
and cleaning plus Factor has more than
34 weekly options plus over 45 add-ons
you can even get get cold pressed juices
shakes and smoothies beyond that factor
offers Gourmet plus meals as part of
your weekly options Gourmet sides
include premium produce like broccoli
and broccolini and perfectly complement
your Gourmet protein which can be Surf
and surf that shrimp and salmon or surf
and turf that shrimp and steak and I can
tell you from personal experience even
after reheating the steak is so good
it's not dry it's not tough It's just
good this month I got some creamy dry
tomato chicken I've gotten this before
but I'm telling you folks this is so
freaking good so head to factor75.com or
click the link below and use the code
rockstars50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box once again that's
factor75.com and use the code rockstars
50 to get 50 off your first Factor box
so Oppenheimer I have to admit my bias
here Oppenheimer is a movie designed
more for someone like me a disciple of
Christopher Nolan's filmography and
World War II history and just process
stories Starry Matt Damon with huge
implications and I can say Oppenheimer
is truly one of Nolan's greatest films
the way this movie shifts point of view
from from vibrant colors of J Robin
Oppenheimer to the Stark black and white
of well Stark is a structural return to
form for Christopher Nolan bringing him
back to his work in Memento I think a
good Storyteller can take a character
you initially have little connection
with and make you see the whole world
through their eyes so that you feel the
terror the anxiety the Elation as much
as they do watching this movie over
three hours reminded me of the whole
sensation of the docking sequence in
interstellar when a task is not possible
but it's necessary and wanting the hero
to simultaneously succeed well in this
case also really not wanting him to at
all that said the movie does not need to
be three hours and the last hour does
partake in some indulgent excesses I
don't think most audiences will hold
that against the film but at the end of
the day I don't think I or you will ever
forget it so nine out of ten now I've
said in several videos on the Deep dive
that every American movie is trying to
be either The Wizard of Oz or Citizen
Kane and I owe you all a separate video
breaking down what that really means but
essentially Barbie is aiming for The
Wizard of Oz both internally and the
references of the movie and structurally
as the story of a young woman waking up
from a dream but Oppenheimer is aiming
for Citizen Kane as is almost a
documentary point of view assessment of
a cryptic American figure as a
soul-searching cautionary tale but both
of these movies are tackling a third
cinematic touch point that also should
be mentioned in the same sentence as
those other two films Stanley Kubrick's
2001 A Space Odyssey that film is a
massive influence on Christopher Nolan
and her Stellar was really his version
of that film and Oppenheimer explores
similar themes of the dangers of
technology and Mankind's desperate
Sprint forward despite the consequences
the gadget weapon in this movie at Los
Alamos is essentially this movie's
monolith and Killian Murphy's eyes is
essentially the eye of Hal but Barbie
holy crap this movie freaking opens with
an amazing shot by Shadow homage of
Kubrick's prologue from 2001 A Space
Odyssey that we saw in the very first
teaser for the film and in this movie
The monolith is Barbie herself and how
she goes from a tool an object and
evolves into sentience and free will but
unlike Oppenheimer Barbie aims to leave
us optimistic about that paradigm shift
and kind of encouraged us to love our
artificial icons for the soul we
assigned to them and in a way that I
would say just kind of feels a little
bit more icky and commercialized than
say Toy Story but both films will scald
your rods and cones in your eyes with
their vibrancy and both demand to be
seen on a huge screen and both are going
to be dominating your conversations in
the weeks ahead but I want to know from
you what's your plan to see these movies
and if you have seen either already how
do you rate them and how do you
recommend people watch them my Easter
egg breakdown of Barbie is coming
tomorrow to the main rock stars Channel
my analysis of Oppenheimer is going to
take a bit more time for me to unpack
this movie it's going to come next week
subscribe to all three of our channels
for analysis of the titles you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]